I EXPECT A HIGH PACE BUT DALAL
DIFFERENCE.
>> SHOT BLOCKED.
HERE HE GOES, JA6 -- RO
OPENS IT U
ROBERTSON.
CREATES THAT
OPENING, AND DOESN'T
HIT ANYBODY IN FRONT DO
WITH IT.
WIDE OFF OF BRADEN
TO DO BETTER
CERTAINLY WITH THESE
CHANCES.
IT WON'T GO DOWN AS
A POWER PLAY GOAL
S
COMING TO THE NET TO
START THE POWER PLAYL R.
GO TO THE SLOTT BACK.
>> COMING INTO THIS
GAME, GOALS AGAINST.T.
AWAY.AY
BEFORE THE GAME FOR
HITTING THAT 400
MARK.
SCORED TWICE ON
BL GAME.
THEY CAN MOVE THE
PUCK QUICKLY.
BRENDAN:N:
REDIRECTED BY
PAVELSKI, THERE, ON
THE BACKSISIGAME.
>> PASS OFF
RADULOV'S STICK.
RIGHT IN FRONT.T NEVER E
IT TO THE GOAL. WINNIPE.
>> HE'S
GET OUT OF THE ZONE.
AND STEPHENSON TAKES
WILL BE THE ONE TO
TAKE THER  D
YOU KNOW THAT HE'S
BEEN IT.
BRENDAN: PART OF THE
PENALTY KILL,
PAVELSKIS -- A
LITTLESAR, NEAR
CIRCLET
THE OTHER END,
PIETRANGELO LEADS IT SH
OF COURSE, HE'S
TALKING ABOUT HIS
BUDDY REAVES, AND HE
DOES SHOOT
PACIORETTY STEERS IT
DOWN.
TAKE A LOO
BRENDA PASSING
PLAY AND STONE IS
THERE FOR THE
REBOUND.STONE THERE,
HOLTBY